uh will AI kill us all yes
so
uh what do you think about this one this
this what do you think is the core
argument here
that uh the development of AGI perhaps
but I said uh will destroy human
civilization no first of all you just
did a sleight of hand because we went
from talking about AI to AGI
is there a fundamental difference there
I don't know what's AGI uh what's AI
what's inside I know what AI is AI is
machine learning
I think we don't know what the bottom of
the well of machine learning is or what
the ceiling is because just uh to call
something machine learning or just the
cause of the statistics or just to call
it math or computation doesn't mean you
know uh nuclear weapons are just physics
so it's it it's to me it's very
interesting and surprising how far
machine learning no but we knew that
nuclear physics would lead to weapons
that's why the scientists of that era
were always in this huge dispute about
building the weapons this is different
ages different as machine learningly do
we know we don't know but this is my
point it's different we actually don't
know but and and this is where you the
sleight of hand kicks in right this is
where it goes from being a scientific
topic to being a religious topic
um and that's what that's why I
specifically called out that because
that's what happens I do the vocabulary
shift and all of a sudden you're talking
about something totally that's not
actually real well then maybe you could
also uh as part of that Define the
Western tradition of millennialism yes
end of the world apocalypse apocalypse
calls um well so we live in we of course
live in a judeo Christian but primarily
Christian kind of saturated you know
kind of Christian post-christian
secularized Christian you know kind of
world in the west
um and of course Court of Christianity
is the idea of the second coming and and
you know the revelations and you know
Jesus returning and thought the
Thousand-Year you know Utopia on Earth
and then the you know the Rapture and
like all stuff you know we don't we you
know we collectively you know as a
society we don't necessarily take all
that fully seriously now so what we do
is we create our secularized versions of
that we keep we keep looking for Utopia
we keep looking for you know basically
the end of the world and so what you see
over over decades is basically a pattern
of these sort of of these of these of is
this this is what calls are this is how
Cults form as they form around some
theory of the end of the world and so
the people's Temple called the Manson
called the heavens gate called the David
koresh call that you know what they're
all organized around is like there's
going to be this thing that's going to
happen that's going to basically bring
civilization crashing down and then we
have this special Elite group of people
who are going to see it coming and
prepare for it and then they're the
people who are either going to stop it
or are failing stopping it they're going
to be the people who survive to the
other side and ultimately get credit for
having been right why is that so
compelling do you think like uh because
it satisfies this very deep need we have
for Transcendence and meaning
that got Stripped Away when we became
secular yeah but what why is the
Transcendence involved the destruction
of human civilization because like how
like how plausible it's it's like a very
deep psychological thing because it's
like how plausible how plausible is it
that we live in a world where
everything's just kind of all right
all right how exciting is that right
that's the Deep question I'm asking why
is it not exciting to live in a world
where everything's just all right does
it I think uh you know most of the
animal kingdom would be so happy we just
all right yeah because that means
survival why are we uh maybe that's what
it is why are we Conjuring up things to
worry about so C.S Lewis called it the
god-shaped hole so there's a god-shaped
hole in The Human Experience
Consciousness Soul whatever you want to
call it where there's got to be
something that's bigger than all this
there's got to be something Transcendent
there's got to be something that is
bigger right bigger a bigger purpose a
bigger meaning
and so we have run the experiment of you
know we're just going to use science and
rationality and kind of you know
everything's just going to kind of be as
it appears and a large number of people
have found that very deeply wanting and
have constructed narratives and by this
is the story of the 20th century right
communism right was one of those
communism was a was a form of this uh
Nazism was a form of this
um you know some people um you know you
can see movements like this playing out
all over the world right now so you
could start the kind of devil a kind of
source of evil and we're going to
transcend Beyond it yeah and the
millinarians the millionaire is kind of
when you see a millionaire and cult they
put a really specific point on it which
is end of the world right there there is
some change coming and that change
that's coming is so profound and so
important that it's either going to lead
to Utopia or hell on Earth right
um and it is going to and then you know
it's like what if you actually knew that
that was going to happen right what
would you what what would you do right
how would you prepare yourself for it
how would you come together with a group
of like-minded people right how would
you what would you do would you plan
like hashes of weapons in the woods
would you like you know I don't know if
it's create under underground bunkers
would you you know spend your life
trying to figure out a way to avoid
having it happen yeah that's a really
compelling exciting idea to uh to have a
club over to have to have a to have a
little bit of trial like a get together
on a Saturday night and drink some beers
and talk about the the end of the world
and how are you you are the only ones
who have figured it out yeah and then
and then once you lock in on that like
how can you do anything else with your
life like this is obviously the thing
that you have to do and then and then
there's a psychological effect you
alluded to there's a psychological
effect if you take a set of True
Believers and you leave them to
themselves they get more radical right
because they self-radicalize each other
that said yes it doesn't mean they're
not sometimes right yeah at the end of
the world might be yes correct like they
might be right yeah but like we have
some pamphlets for you
I mean there's I mean we'll talk about
nuclear weapons because if you have a
really interesting little moment that I
learned about in in your essay but you
know sometimes it could be right yeah
yeah because we're still you were
developing more and more powerful
Technologies uh in this case and we
don't know what the impact they will
have on human civilization well we can
highlight all the different predictions
about how it will be positive but the
risks are there
and you discuss some of them well the
Steel Man the steel man is the Steel Man
actually the steel man and his
refutation are the same which is you
can't predict what's going to happen
right you right you can't rule out that
this will not end everything right but
the response to that is you have just
made a completely non-scientific claim
yeah you've made a religious claim out
of scientific claim how does it get
disproven there is and there's no by
definition with these kinds of claims
there's no way to disprove them yeah
right um and so there's no you just go
right on the list there's no hypothesis
there's no testability of the hypothesis
there's no um way to falsify the
hypothesis there's no way to measure
progress along the arc like it's just
all completely missing and so it's not
scientific and well I don't think it's
completely missing it's it's somewhat
missing so for example the the the the
people that say ah is going to kill all
of us
I mean they usually have ideas about how
to do that whether it's the paperclip
maximizer or um you know it escapes
there's mechanism by which you can
imagine it killing all humans models and
to you can disprove it by saying there
is um
there's a limit
to uh the speed at which intelligence
increases
maybe show that uh
like the sort of rigorously really
described model like how it could happen
and say no there here's a physics
limitation there's a physical limitation
to how these systems would actually do
damage like human civilization and it is
possible they will kill 10 to 20 percent
of the population but it seems
impossible for them to kill uh 99
there's practical counter arguments
right so you mentioned basically what I
described as the thermodynamic counter
argument which is sitting here today
it's like where the evil AGI gets the
gpus yeah because like they don't exist
so you're gonna have a very frustrated
baby evil AGI who's going to be like
trying to buy Nvidia stock or something
to get them to finally make some chips
um right so the the serious form of that
is the thermodynamic argument which was
like okay where's the energy going to
come from where's the processors are
going to be running where is the data
center going to be happening how is this
going to be happening in Secrets such
that you know you know so so that's a
practical counter argument to The
Runaway AJ I think I have a but I have a
and we can argue that discuss that I
have a deeper objection to it which is
it's this is all forecasting it's all
modeling it's all it's all future
prediction it's all future hypothesizing
it's not science
sure it is not it is it is the opposite
of science so the Carl Sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof right these are
extraordinary claims the policies that
are being called for right to prevent
this are of extraordinary magnitude and
I think we're going to cause
extraordinary damage and this is all
being done on the basis of something
that is literally not scientific it's
not a testable hypothesis so the moment
you say AI is going to kill all of us
therefore we should ban it or that we
should uh regulate all that kind of
that's when it starts getting serious or
start you know military airstrikes and
data centers oh boy right
and like
yeah this one's get starts well so it
starts getting real so here's the
problem of millionaire and Cults they
have a hard time staying away from
violence
HIPAA violence is so fun
if you're on the right end of it they
have a hard time avoiding balance the
reason they have a hard time affording
balances if you actually believe the
claim right then what would you do to
stop the end of the world well you would
do anything right yeah and so and this
is where you get and again if you just
look at the history of millionaire and
Cults this is where you get the people's
Temple and everybody killing themselves
in the jungle and this is where you get
Charles Manson and you know setting in
need to kill kill the pigs like this is
the problem with these they have a very
hard time to run the line at actual
violence and I think I think in this
case there's they're I mean they're
already calling for it like today and
you know where this goes from here is
they get more worked up like I think
it's like really concerning okay but
that's kind of the extreme so you know
the extremes of anything I wrote I was
concerning
it's also possible to kind of believe
that AI has a very high likelihood of
killing all of us
uh but there's and therefore we should
uh maybe consider uh slowing development
or regulating so not violence or any of
these kinds of things but saying like
all right let's let's take a pause here
you know your biological weapons nuclear
weapons like
this is like serious
stuff we should be careful so it is
possible to kind of have a more rational
response right if you believe this risk
is real